obviously I want to ask you about
Superman and I I know you can't talk
about anything coming up because it's
all being figured out but I am curious
what was it like for you putting on the
suit again getting ready to film The
Cameo because the truth is like what
were your emotions because the truth is
it might have been over it might not not
have ever happened again
it was a it was a powerful moment for me
a meaningful moment
um I
I was given a choice of of which which
suit I wanted to wear and and I went
straight for the Man of Steel suit uh
that one holds the most Nostalgia for me
and and the most meaning and to put that
back on
understand there in front of a mirror
suited up again it's
the suit holds a special power and and
there's no there's no way of getting
around there even if you're the one
wearing it and
to to see myself standing back in that
suit was a is a meaningful moment it's
difficult to describe
um many years hoping planning
striving doing everything I can to to
get back into it and then finally be
able to get back into it uh
it meant a lot and it's something that I
won't quickly forget